[Music]
enourage you all to listen to what Dr.
Wallik has to say. You're going to be
entertained. He's funny as heck. But
more importantly, it's going to be life
transforming, especially if you're sick.
Especially if you're dealing with some
kind of illness. Especially if a doctor
has told you that you're going to be on
this medication for the rest of your
life and there's nothing you can do
about it. When you hear Dr. Wallace
speak, you're going to say, like I said
when I first heard him speak, it's
obvious. So would you please join me in
welcoming a good friend, a colleague,
truly an inspiration, my nutritional
mentor, and somebody who's just a great
honor and a privilege to say that he is
my friend, Dr. Joel Wallik.
Okay. Thank you, Ben. Thank you so much
for the kind introduction and thank each
and every one of you for being here on a
Friday evening. You could be out
partying. Appreciate you being here. And
for those of you who don't know me, just
very quickly, the thing that makes my
view different is that I have a degree
in agriculture. And in agriculture, we
don't have health insurance for animals.
And we need to maximize our income uh
from raising animals. And so we had to
learn how to maximize their lifespan,
maximize their production of meat and
milk and eggs from the same amount of
feed. Uh we had to have perfect
pregnancies, no early births where they
needed three months in in the incubator.
We had to have no birth defects and the
animals who were born on the farm had to
reach either reproductive age or market
weight without need for health care. We
did that with vitamins and minerals.
Went on to veterary school, became a
veterinarian. Uh halfway through
veterary school, I graduated a school.
So I was a graduate student. Began to
take pathology courses. Wrote the first
paper on a mass die- off in America from
pollution. I'm sure it happened many
times before, but nobody recognized it.
Got it published and that kind of
redirected my whole life. uh graduated
veterary school, taught pathology up at
Iowa State University for a year and
then got uh invited by Marlon Perkins
from the old Mutual Mahal Wild Kingdom
show and I'd worked for him through high
school to go to Africa and work on the
white rhino conservation project in the
elephant conservation project. Caught
200 white rhinos, shipped them back to
the states and if you go and you see a
white rhino in a wild animal park or
zoo, it's probably one of that I caught
or maybe even offsprings are the ones
that I caught. After two years of
working on those projects, a Perkins
sent me a letter and said, "Look, I I've
got a big grant from the National
Institutes of Health. We need to study
the causes of death in zoo animals and
the people who live in close proximity
to the zoo animals because they have the
same air, the same water, the same food
sources. We want to find out if
pollution or nutrition have something to
do with their causes of death." came
back, worked on that project for 10
years. And the short version is I did
over 20,000 autopsies and 10 million
chemistries on 17,000 some change of
over 454 species of zoo animals and
3,000 humans. And the bottom line of the
study was that every animal, every human
being who dies of what we would call
natural causes, not trauma, but natural
causes, uh, died of a nutritional
deficiency, disease, and not pollution.
Now the book that came out of that 1,200
pages in the Smithsonian Institute as a
national treasure and I'm just a young
kid and I was really very proud of that
and they moved me around from zoo to zoo
university university so I could deal
with more species of animals and
different people eating different things
from all over the place and again to
make a long story short in 1977 I was
working at Emory University in the Yorks
Primate Center in Atlanta Georgia and
discovered the first documented case of
a nonhuman with cystic fibrosis. I'm
sure people had seen it before but they
didn't recognize it. But because my vast
experience when it came to autopsies, I
recognized this immediately as cystic
fibrosis. Got a confirmed by the experts
and then when I told them it wasn't
genetically transmitted that I could
create as many baby monkeys as they
wanted with cystic fibrosis because it
was a deficiency of a single mineral
selenium during pregnancy or shortly
after pregnancy and I could produce as
many monkeys they wanted. They fired me.
They said, "We must be sniffing glue."
Everybody knows that cystic fibrosis is
genetically transmitted in and there's
no way it could be something you could
prevent and reverse and create. And so
to make a long story short again went
back to school became a naturopathic
physician began treating humans in 1978
and been doing it ever since. It's 36
years been treating humans with
nutrition and doing the the thing with
nutrition as we did in animals. So what
you're going to get is a view from
agriculture veterary medicine as a
comparative pathologist and as a primary
care physician. So, you're going to get
four different views of the same
subject. So, bear with me and hold your
questions until later. Now, in the
beginning, doctors thought that all
diseases were caused by evil spirits or
little gods sitting on planets. And if
you burn enough goats to the evil
spirits, they would spare you of
disease. And if you burn enough goats to
the good spirits, they would protect
you. That lasted for thousands and
thousands of years. I don't know if any
of you ever heard of the paintings in
the Lascow caves in France. These
paintings are dated to 28,000 to 32,000
years ago. And people who are very very
religious and know, wait a minute, wall,
the earth is only 5,000 years old. Now,
I live in hotel rooms and I've read the
Old Testament, the New Testament
literally dozens of times over 36 years
I've been on the road. You can tell
there's no place in there that says the
earth is only 5,000 years old. So, I
don't care if it's 5,000 years old,
32,000 years old. God made it and that's
all that makes me happy. But in these
paintings, and you have to appreciate
that those paintings lasted 28,000 to
32,000 years. How often do you have to
paint your house? Once every 5 years.
They knew something about pigments, uh,
very interesting stuff. And they were
painted by shamans and medicine men and
medicine women. And they told health
stories and disease stories. And then
formal religions came along. And formal
religions and science conflicted with
each other. One of my favorite stories,
of course, is Galileo. And he wasn't the
only one, but he was one of the more
vocal ones. and he wrote scientific
papers on the fact that the earth and
the other planets circled around the
sun. Prior to that, the churches all
believed that the sun rotated around the
earth and the inquisition committee from
the from the Catholic Church at the time
condemned Galileo to death for being
sacriiggious and going against the
church's teachings and belief. And
fortunately for him, a cardinal, there
was a cardinal when he was a young man,
uh, became pope at the time and was able
to commute his death sentence from being
burned at the stake to house arrest for
the rest of his life. And so that's kind
of how there was a conflict between
churches and science at that time,
several thousand years ago, physicians
and philosophers believed that there was
a cure all. There was, we only had to
look for it. There'd be one treatment
that would cure everything was called
the panacea. That's where the word
panacea came from. And if you could
learn how to transmute lead into gold,
you were smart enough to figure out that
one cure for everything. It was called
Alchemy Sorcerer. And even Disney came
out with a movie, The Sorcerer. After a
while, the doctors just got into trying
to turn lead into gold for the gold, not
for the panacea. Now, Louis Pasteure
came along in the 1800s, and he came up
with a germ theory. He was a a
microbiologist, and he was a chemist for
the wine industry to prevent wine from
becoming vinegar. He came up with the
idea of heating it to knock down the
population of yeast and bacteria to stop
the fermentation process. The same way
with milk and it was named
pasteurization after himself. Again he
came up with a germ theory and in the
germ theory he said there are certain
bacteria because they had just had a
microscope invented by a Dutch
eyeglasses maker von Luen Hoke and he
could actually see bacteria and he could
grow bacteria from people who had
pneumonia and menitis and many other
diseases and then he could take those
bacteria and inject it back into other
people and to animals and get the same
disease and doctors fought him over that
tooth and nail that would fight him over
that and so he had to set up an
experiment right in the center of Paris.
He got to two groups of 25 sheep each
group and he gave one group a
vaccination which he created against
anthrax which is a disease killed people
and animals and the other group got a
dummy vaccination. It was just a water
being injected instead of the
vaccination. Both groups he injected
with heavy doses of the of the bacteria
that caused anthrax basillus anthraasis.
And in the group that was vaccinated
only one out of the 25 died. In the
group that was not vaccinated all 25
died. And the reporters were there
thousands of people were watching this
as it went along. And so he became very
famous over the anthrax thing. He was
also the guy even though he didn't know
the term viruses. He was the one to
first come up with a post-exposure
vaccine for rabies as a virus thing. And
he figured out how to do that. Very very
smart guy. Took a long time for doctors
to agree that yes, there were germs. And
once they figured out where there was
germs, they said, you know, everything
is caused by germs, even cancer and
insanity and so forth. And a guy by the
name of Ko came along and said, no, no,
you have to isolate the bug, make sure
that it's the bug. inject it back into
susceptible host, cause the disease
again, isolate it again, get the same
bug, then you know it caused a disease.
Guy's name was KO, K O C H. About the
same time, there was a priest in Austria
by the name of Gregor Mendel and he was
a very smart guy and he had taken many
courses in what we would call today
calculus and he could predict numbers
and things. And um because he was very
smart and a detailed kind of guy, the
cardinal in the parish that he was the
priest in put him in charge of creating
peas for priests to eat during the
winter time. And they had hotouses where
they grow these peas during the winter
time. And there were peas with red
flowers. There were peas with white
flowers. And every once in a while
there'd be one volunteer, a dozen of
them volunteer on the path between the
two different hotouses. And these were
ones that weren't planted. They would
just pop up and they had pink flowers.
And he reasoned that they were a mix or
a hybrid between the red flower and the
white flower pea plants. And he could do
experiments with crossbreeding and so
forth. And he came up with hybrids. He
came up with dominance and recessives.
And so he's kind of the father of
genetics. But he never related the
genetic concept to diseases, just life
itself. At the same time, Charles Darwin
came along and Charles Darwin did not
know about Gregor Mendel, but Gregor
Mendle did know about Darwin. Darwin was
a son of a very wealthy Englishman. Uh
they were landed. They had 10,000 acre
estates. And his mother was very
wealthy. She was from the Wedgewood
family, the English dishwear company.
And very interesting stuff. And he
collected bugs and feathers and
eggshells. and he would shoot birds and
little animals and make collections. And
when he was 22 years old, he wrote a
paper for the newspaper of the Royal
Society. It was very prestigious for
anybody, let alone a 22-year-old guy to
write the paper. And he wrote the paper
on invertebrates, little palyps, would
make sponges and briefs. And he was
hired by the British Navy when he was 22
years old to go around the earth in the
HMS Beagle, a British warship, and build
artificial reefs. And he was so
successful at this, they hired him for
another three years. So for a total of 5
years, Darwin was going to places that
nobody else had ever been before and
building these reefs. But he was also
collecting animals that nobody had seen
before. And he recognized immediately,
well not immediately, he recognized in 5
years when he wrote his book on the
origin of species that parents of the
babies were passing on information.
Human beings had babies who were human
beings. Dogs had babies who were dogs.
Puppies uh cattle had babies who were
calves. Um oak trees had babies that
were oak trees. and he'd find these
weird animals and he would shoot them
and bring them back and taxiderermy them
because nobody would believe there was
such things as penguins living in the
Antarctic and so forth. So this is what
he did. His book was on the origin of
species. And Darwin never said that that
man came from apes, but he said all
things, all living things, whether
you're a tree or a tulip or a oak tree
or a human being or a hummingbird,
passed on information to the young.
Well, to sell newspapers, the reporters
said that he said that men came from
apes. And that wasn't what he said. He
said, "All things pass on information is
all he said." Now, his cousin Francis
Golton, whose mother was Darwin's
mother's sister, also from the Wedgewood
family. Francis Golton was also from a
very wealthy landed family and um he was
in university and his roommate was a guy
by the name of Arthur Conand Doyle, the
author of Sherlock Holmes. And Francis
Gton was the model that became Sherlock
Holmes in the book in the series
Sherlock Holmes. In the day, people were
just learning about fingerprints. And
part of the parlor tricks they would do
when you'd come to a party or to give
you a piece of white paper, put your
fingers on some ink, and everybody would
make several pages with their
fingerprints and they would exchange
fingerprints. And he recognized by
looking at these very carefully with a
magnifying glass that fingerprints were
different from person to person. And
Francis Golton came up with the idea to
use fingerprints to track criminals.
Very smart guy. And that's why he was
the model for Sherlock Holmes. He also
said, you know, we can speed up human
evolution like we do in animals by
selective breeding just like we do in
animals. That's why they have livestock
shows and dog shows and horse shows.
They want to get the very best phenotype
or the very best physical example of
male horses and female horses. And when
the fo is born, it's going to be
perfect. Same with dogs and and same way
with geese and chickens and whatever you
might be breeding. He said, "We can do
the same thing with human beings." And
he was very benevolent. He went out and
he started a dating club and he'd hand
out invitations to people he considered
to be perfect examples of perfect
humanity included IQ and intelligence
and speed and athletes and strength and
both the men and women had to be six
foot tall blondhaired and blue-eyed
which he called the master race. Now
this was in the 1800 began to sound
familiar. He would give out invitations
and he would have these tall young
blonde head and blue-eyed women meet
with tall blonde blue-eyed men at these
banquetss and just by socializing he
figured some of them would fall in love
with the another one and they would get
married and have more babies like them.
Well, after the first world war, the
League of Nations broke up Germany.
Germany originally went all the way from
Russia all the way to Spain. It was the
biggest nation in Europe. They broke
them up into their provinces became
individual countries. Hungary,
Czechoslovakia, Holland, and so forth.
Poland after the Second World War, there
was a Nermberg trials and the Nuremberg
trials was to find out who were the most
horrible of the war criminals. Uh they
murdered 16 million people. They
experimented on them and did horrific
stuff and they certainly didn't try any
German generals for war crimes because
they were just good soldiers. Uh they
didn't put any bureaucrats on trial for
war crimes because they were just
pushing paper and never made any
decisions or shot or killed anybody or
butchered anybody or experimented
anybody. And so most of the people who
were executed for war crimes were
medical doctors. The example was Joseph
Mangle. He was called the angel of death
because particularly twins. He would
kill one and do experiments on the other
one based on what he find the other one.
He would kill people with birth defects,
cleft pallet, belly button hernas,
people who had Down syndrome, cerebral
palsy, older people who were infirmed.
They would just kill them because they
were useless. They were in his terms
useless eaters. They just took the
assets of Germany and didn't do anything
productive. Even if you were Jewish, who
they wanted to eliminate. If you were
physically able to work, they would put
you to work until you couldn't work
anymore, they wouldn't feed you because
that was a waste of food. So when when
you worked yourself almost to death,
they would gas you. Now, everybody knows
people who were found guilty of war
crimes were hung. And of course, most of
the people who were hung for war crimes
were medical doctors at the end of the
war. Now, there's some medical doctors
who did horrific crimes and they weren't
executed. And that's because they had
all this data from the murder and
experimentation on 60 million people.
And they would call in uh to generals
and say, "Look, I've got all this
information here from all the
experiments we've done over the last 5
years, and I can give them to you in
exchange for a pardon. If you don't
pardon me, I'll just burn them and
you'll never get all the information
that we collected." And many of these
Nazi doctors were pardoned because they
turned over the information to US forces
and they were made professors in US
medical schools. All this information is
a book that's out now, not mine,
somebody else's book. It's called
Operation Paperclip. Everybody knows
about Warner von Brown, the rocket
scientists we took from the Nazis. But
we also got the doctors. Also, all the
pharmaceutical companies we have now,
Bayer, Fizer, Ro, Eli, Lily were Nazi
pharmaceutical companies, which they
made their money to run the war. We took
them over for reparations. This is how
we got paid for the cost of the war was
pharmaceutical companies. They turned
them into publicly traded companies. And
of course, and originally the government
owned all the stock. They sold it to the
general public and that's how the
government got paid for running the war.
Now, our doctors weren't innocent. Our
doctors did the same thing here in
America. They did experiments on people.
One of the more famous ones, not the
only one, but one of the more famous
ones was a Tuskegee experiment on 400
black men in America who had syphilis
and they said, "Look, we're going to
give you this new penicellin." But they
only gave them injections of water
because they wanted to see if these guys
would die from the same terrible
symptoms that white guys died from.
Published many scientific papers on the
subject. In Canada, they did the same
thing. They had what they called
resident schools and they would go into
the Indian reservations in Canada and
actually kidnap the kids from there
saying look we're going to give them a
better education. We're going to feed
them better. They're struggling here on
the reservations and nobody wanted to
believe what was going on in there but
they were experimenting these kids. They
gave them tuberculosis and they tried
different drugs to see which one would
save them and which ones failed. And
this came out this was March of this
year because they found 50,000 bodies of
kids under the age of 10 in Canada that
had been killed during this program.
50,000 in Canada were killed in the same
type of experiments that were done in
Germany. When did this all translate
into us being the sickest country in the
world?
1901 it began. It actually began in 3:00
in the afternoon Monday, September 4th,
1882. We'll get to that in a minute. But
1901, something very dramatic happened.
A product was invented to be a machinery
lubricant called Krisco. See, Proctor
and Gamble didn't invent Krisco. They
didn't did not invent hydrogenated oils.
The process of fat hardening was
invented in 1901 by Wilham Norman,
another German chemist working on a
machine oil factory trying to find a
cheap replacement for machine oil which
is made from sew it which is beef fat
and they couldn't get it. Well, he came
up with using cottonseed oil and our
corn oil that had a copper co-actor and
then they bubble hydrogen through it and
boil it and all this kind of stuff and
they would get Crisco. And Proctor and
Gamble recognized they can make a lot
more money selling it as food than they
did as a machinery lubricant. But they
couldn't go against the butter and the
cream and the lard that people have been
using for hundreds and hundreds and
hundreds of years. So how did they do
that? They hired a guy by the name of
Anel Keys. And Ancel Keys had gotten a
degree in anthropology and a medical
degree from the University of Minnesota.
And Anel Keys was one of the founders of
the American Heart Association. Death
from coronary heart disease became was
rare until 1925 after they started
selling Crisco to everybody. The Anel
Keys they raised $1.7 million which made
the American Heart Association one of
the more wealthy of the medical
associations in America and they went
crazy changing everybody's ideas about
eating meat and cholesterol and so forth
because they wanted to sell more Crisco
which made the American Heart
Association richer. Now at the same time
all the experiments were being done was
they showed very clearly that the people
who had the higher blood cholesterols
were the ones who lived longer had less
heart disease and had no Alzheimer
disease. The lower you got your
cholesterol the more heart disease the
more Alzheimer's disease and the younger
you died. So it boils down to personal
ambition, bad science, politics and bias
derailed nutrition policy over the past
half century and caused America to be
the sickest country. Because the
American Heart Association wanted the
money, they would buy great ads like
this. They made them almost Norman
Rockwell pictures made to help take the
fat worry out of good eating. Bam,
you're dead. Anel Keys was so famous
that he actually got his picture on the
cover of Time magazine. And this was in
1961. Dr. Anel Keys, father of the low
saturated fat and high oil diet and
drove Crisco as a replacement for butter
and lard. He's the one who killed
America. Time magazine, December 2008.
The sorry state of American health. You
have to appreciate we spend more money
for health care than all of the 204
nations in the world combined. We spend
more money each year than 204 nations.
We rank 92nd in healthfulness. There's
91 other nations whose peoples are
healthier than us. We're ranked 60th in
longevity. There's 59 other nations
whose peoples live longer than us. And
God forgive us, we ranked 41st in live
birth and first month survivability of
our babies. In this article, they say
our children will be the first
generation who do not live as long as
their parents because of Anel Keys.
Harvard Medical School says 52% of
medical doctors America are on street
drugs or prescription drugs or alcohol
during the working day. This came out
for 1614. Sometimes I go into the
bathroom in the middle of a long surgery
to take medication introvenously.
Another doctor says I was absolutely
impaired using narcotics while working
as a doctor and no one ever tripped onto
it or noticed. ARP monthly bulletin,
American Association Retired People
Monthly Bulletin, March 2012. The worst
place to be in America when you're sick
is an American hospital. And I took some
of these out of the article so you could
see what they're talking about. It says
the number of American patients who die
each year from American hospital errors
is equal to four jumbo jets crashing
each week. That's 1500 people a week,
3,000 every two weeks, 6,000 a month,
72,000 a year. How many would fly
commercial airlines if you knew that
they killed 72,000 passengers every
year? How many would go to and frequent
a particular type of fast food franchise
if you knew that they killed 72,000 of
their patrons every year? Of course,
there's big controversy right now. VA
hospital in Arizona was trying to stay
in budget and so they sidailed hundreds
of patients uh for a month so they
wouldn't break the budget before the end
of their fiscal year. And these 40 of
them died. That's nothing new. This came
out in 1999. There's a big study by the
Department of Veterans Affairs. They
said there's hundreds of thousands of
minor mistakes in the VA system every
year in America. 3,000 which are so
severe that the veteran has to stay
there for the rest of their life in the
VA hospital. Of these 3,000 serious
mistakes, I want you to look at the word
that the Department of Veterans Affairs
use. They said medical doctors and VA
hospitals kill 700 veterans each year.
Last year in Afghanistan, the enemy
killed 375 active military personnel.
You're safer on a field of battle than
you're in a VA hospital. God forgive us.
According to the Wall Street Journal
looking at December 2012, each surgeon
in America makes thousands of errors
each year. 52% are gorked out on drugs
and alcohol. Street drugs, prescription
drugs, and alcohol. Here's one of my
favorite examples. This girl here, young
lady, 28 years old, went into a general
hospital in Orlando, Florida to have her
first baby. The OBGYn who was
intoxicated, cut her arms off at the
elbows, cut her legs off of the groin.
He never had his license suspended for
three seconds. He went out and had
martinis that afternoon. She's never
gotten anything for it. Somebody needs
to go to jail here. This is one of my
favorites because it shows you very
clearly where they got the information.
This was the USA Today in February 2007.
Look at the title. It's
self-explanatory. Patient protect
thyself. And the data came from the
Institute of Medicine, which is kind of
a ethical watchdog for the medical
profession. And then the Journal of the
American Medical Association, the most
prestigious medical journal in America,
certainly maybe the world. And then the
Centers for Disease Control, which is
the watchdog for the federal government,
it's in Atlanta, Georgia. And their
combined data, this is a yearly figure,
said each year in America, medical
doctors kill, injure, and infect 15
million of their patients in their
workplace. Each year in America, medical
doctors kill, injure, and infect 15
million of their patients in their
hospitals and clinics. How many would
fly commercial airlines if you knew they
killed, injured, infected 15 million
passengers every year? Nobody would fly.
Yet, you still go to doctors. I find
that amazing how much control the
doctors have over you. Everybody knows
about Bernie Maidoff. He he went to jail
for life for defrauding his investors of
$3 billion. Well, this came out in
September of 2012. Front page article in
many newspapers around America. Now,
this is not government. The the title US
healthcare waste $750 billion. You you
kind of get the sense that is government
making the waste? No. When you read the
article, it says your doctor. Your
doctor, not the government. your doctor
out of every dollar that he bills you
and your insurance company, 30 cents of
it is a fraudulent billing. 30 cents of
it is either for procedures he's billing
for that he didn't do, but he needed the
money for his kids to go to Harvard and
all that kind of stuff for their tuition
or his wife wanted a um Mercedes
convertible. And so he just took your ID
number for your insurance company, build
them or he did something for you that
you really didn't need and he build for
that 30 cents out of every dollar. It
amounts to $750 billion a year. is
threequarters of a trillion dollars each
year, one-third of the American medical
budget. And not a single doctor gets his
license suspended for 3 seconds. Not a
single doctor had his license revoked.
Nobody goes to jail. Nobody gets the
equivalent fine as a parking ticket.
Bernie made off went to life for $3
billion. Doctors get a walk for
threequarters of a trillion. Start
breaking that down a little bit. The
Center for Disease Control, again, the
federal agency in Atlanta, Georgia,
tracks his stuff just in hospitals alone
each year. Not private office and
clinics. Just in hospitals alone,
medical doctors infect two million
patients because they don't wash their
hands after they go potty. And of those
2 million infections, 90,000 die. What
would happen if Iran or North Korea were
to send over intercontinental ballistic
missiles with biological weapons infect
2 million people in our large population
centers? Miami, Atlanta, New York, New
York, New Jersey, Philadelphia, places
like Cincinnati, Ohio, Chicago,
Dallas, Texas, LA, and kill 90,000. This
is a yearly figure. This isn't one time.
This goes on and on and on year after
year after year, and nobody seems to
care. But we'd go to war with Iran. We'd
vaporize them with an atomic weapon if
they'd do that to one of our cities. But
the medical doctors have legislated
themselves into being a protected
monopoly, self-p policing. They've also
legislated all of their competition into
being fifth class citizens. Quacks who
cannot be paid by insurance. When you
get a roof on your house or put a
irrigation system in your house, you're
going to get three, four, five bids or
more. After you choose what you think is
the best one based on what they're
telling you and the contract they
propose for you, you're still going to
before you sign the contract, you're
going to go to the Better Business
Bureau and see if there's any complaints
about these companies you're looking at.
You go to the same doctor year after
year after year after year for 20, 30
years, whatever he says you do. You
don't even question it. You don't even
go get a second opinion. And that's
what's killing America. One bacteria,
Ciff Claustrium difficil, a human poop
bacteria, kills 30,000 each year in
hospitals alone. That's onethird of
those 90,000 that are killed by
infections are killed by Cadiff. Only
found in human poop. Doctors give it to
people because they don't wash their
hands after they go potty. Well, in
1993, there are 85,700 of these
infections in American hospitals. 17
years later, 2010, it went up 400% to
almost 350,000 from 85,000. And so, does
this give you a sense that doctors are
really working hard to solve the
problem? No. There's no consequences why
it looks like that. If you were to take
the top 50 doctors who kill a thousand
people a week and hang them and then
take the next thousand doctors who kill
25 a week and put them in jail for life,
the table would look like that, wouldn't
it? Because there's consequences. The
reason why the table looks like this is
there's no consequences.
Now, the Chinese have figured out how to
deal with this. There's two types of
Chinese doctors. The traditional Chinese
medical doctors are called the barefoot
doctors. Um, they go back a thousand
years before Egyptian doctors. Egyptian
doctors came online about 4,000 years
ago. the Chinese traditional Chinese
medical doctors came on a thousand years
before that. Acupuncture herbs, great
writings and so forth. Um the Yellow
Emperor recorded all this stuff. I mean
this goes way way back thousands of
years. And during the Second World War,
the Japanese soldiers were moving ahead
of their supply line. They were starving
and they were poor and they would strip
like locusts. They would strip the
civilian population of everything. And
the doctors had the best shoes. So they
always wanted to get the doctor's shoes.
So the traditional Chinese medical
doctors were called the barefoot
doctors. and they would go out to the
villages and and help people with
acupuncture and herbs and they were
beloved by by the people of the
villages. Well, after the Second World
War, the Chinese sent their very
brightest young medical students to the
United States and Canada and Europe for
Western medical training, and they came
back and began to kill the Chinese
patients just like Western medical
doctors do here in in North America and
Europe. The Chinese have figured out how
to solve the problem. Each year,
grieving families kill 27.3 doctors in
each hospital on the average who kill
their relatives. And this is considered
justifiable homicide. So the
government's now trying to say, "Okay,
come on guys. Let's cool our jets. Let's
not do this anymore. We know it's listed
as justifiable homicide that when uh you
know a doctor kills your father, the
brothers and the sons go and kill the
doctor with axes and hammers and all
those kind because they're not allowed
to have guns. So they have to do with
primitive weapons. And I'm not proposing
that that we kill doctors, but what I am
proposing is we take care of ourselves
enough where we don't need them. If you
don't need them, they'll pack up and
leave.
Couple
more and then we'll get into the
diseases. Deaths by medication error
rising. This came out in 2006. This is a
national story in the United States.
Medication errors. These types of
mistakes are tied to 1.5 million
fatalities and permanent injuries each
year in America alone. And everybody
wants to take medication. I find that
amazing. a federal jury in Lafayette,
Louisiana, lodged a punitive damage
against Eli Lily and their Japanese um
partners for $9 billion over hiding
Acttose risk. Now, what is that?
Acttose, of course, is a extremely
wellrespected drug that's used for
diabetes. I mean, it will lower your
blood sugar, but everybody who takes
Acttose gets cancer. They forgot to tell
you that part. They conspired to keep
that piece secret. And so, a federal
jury dinged them$9 billion dollars. I
thought that was cool. Yet problem is
that's chump change for them. That's
like charging you a nickel for a parking
ticket. None of the guys who were in on
the conspiracy lost their jobs. None of
them got a fine, a parking ticket. They
got nothing. The company got dinged 9
billion. But again, it's like you being
charged a nickel. Hospital care fatal
for some patients. Uh this study was
actually done by the US Department of
Health and Human Services, Office of
Inspector General, which is essentially
the auditor for Medicare. What they did
was look at the monthly kill rate by
medical doctors on seniors, people who
were on Medicare. This is a monthly
figure. Medical doctors kill 15,000
Medicare patients in hospitals with
minor medical procedures and screening
tests. How many over age 65 would fly
commercial airlines if you knew that
they killed 15,000 seniors every month?
That's 180,000 a year. Nobody would fly
if you're over age 65. But you still go
to doctors. Why? Because of insurance.
I'll show you three people, very famous
people that they killed last couple
years were over age 65. Andy Rooney from
60 Minutes was 92 years old. He and his
87y old wife were going to go on a world
cruise for a year and she was nervous
said Andy I'm 87 you're 92 one of us is
going to get sick here and we need to
take a disc with our medical records in
case because we don't even speak the
language is the place we're going so he
agrees they going to the doctor and
while the disc are being burned on the
records his doctor is going through his
papers and say you know Andy you're 90
years old I I can't see where you've
ever had a colonoscopic exam you could
have cancer lurking around in you and he
should have said no I don't have any
blood in my stool I don't I'm not losing
weight I don't have any pelvic pain I
haven't had he changed my bowel habits
and so I'm not going to get a
colonoscopic exam but instead he said oh
okayy Rooney the skeptical guy was a
compliant 90-year-old guy goes in the
next day the doctor sticks a garden hose
up his rump punctures intestine and
three days later he's dead from
paranized belly infection when you look
online obituary no matter what service
you're looking at they all say the same
thing was a news release okay from 60
Minutes they said Mr. Rooney died from
complications of a minor medical
procedure. Wasn't minor for him. It
killed him. And then Dick Clark,
American band stand, 8 years old, goes
in for a physical, complains to his
doctor. He gets up in the middle of the
night to go to the bathroom. The doctor
says, "You're probably having a large
prostate." Sends him urologist.
Urologist exam said, "Yeah, you got a
large prostate, Dick. We need to um cut
part of your prostate gland out. We're
going to put you on prescriptions." And
I could see Dick Clark kind of arguing a
little bit. He said, "Well, I don't
think I need surgery." Well, yes, you
do. Listen, Dick. this is a minor
procedure. Um, you don't have to stay in
the hospital overnight. It's an
outpatient procedure. It's like clipping
your fingernails for goodness sakes. You
come in at 9:00, 9:30, you're done. 1:00
you're on the golf course for goodness
sakes. Don't be a wimp. And he should
have said no. But he said, "Oh, okay."
Goes in at 9:00. 9:30 is dead. The
doctor forgot to tell him was when you
cut on the prostate gland, it releases a
hormone that causes your risk of
thrombotic stroke, coronary thrombosis,
pulary ambulism to go up. Well, he won
the lottery. He got all three and died.
Went at 9:00, 9:30 was dead. But my
favorite is Neil Armstrong, our top
astronaut. first man to walk on the
moon, personally saved two doomed NASA
missions. 82 years old, went in for his
physical. The doctors came out saying
that NASA program must be wonderful.
Neil, you're 82 years old, but you got
the blood work and and the physical body
of a 50-y old guy. The only thing we
find is one coronary artery way down at
the tip has a 3mm wide 30% blockage.
You're not going to have any chest pain
and because it's too low. It had to be
high up in the artery have the pain.
There's really no risk of having a heart
attack because it's too low. It has to
be high up in the in the artery to have
risk for heart attack. But it could be a
progressive thing. And if you let us,
we'd recommend doing a a putting in a
stint R2 and doing a bypass R2. You'll
never have to worry about a heart attack
from these arteries. And he should have
said, "No, no, no." But instead, he
said, "Yes, sir. Let's do it." 3 days
later, he was dead. What he died from?
Complications of an elective
cardiovascular procedure. Elective means
he really didn't need it. All the
doctors went out and had martinis. Gee,
we killed Neil Armstrong. Can you
believe that? Now, if al Qaeda would
have kidnapped him, cut his head off in
YouTube. We have sent in drones to blow
up baby food factories in case they had
biological weapons in there, we'd
certainly send in Seal Team 6 to kill a
bunch of people. But let a doctor kill
our top astronaut. It's okay. Now, to
me, this is the most important part of
life. The first 91 days of pregnancy,
the baby's going down an assembly line.
And like a factory, say making cars,
TVs, refrigerators, tractors, furnaces,
whatever it's making, there has to be
stations where it has all the parts. And
you got a team of guys installing these
parts. are handing them to and the one
guy's putting the parts in. Then it goes
on to the next station. They put in the
parts and it goes to the next station.
If somebody has to run to the bathroom
and there's nobody there to kind of keep
up with it, nobody stops the assembly
line, that furnace or that car will get
to the line of pieces missing. The same
thing happens with babies. There's
pieces missing. This is what causes
birth defects because the mother was
missing something. Well, whose fault is
that? It's the OBGYn. The OBGN is is
responsible for every birth defect you
can name. There's not a single birth
defect that's caused genetically. It's
all caused by nutritional deficiencies
of the embryo. The last six months of
pregnancy is just growth. By the time 91
days goes by, you've got what you got
and then the next six months are just
growth. Anybody here ever hear of things
that are called inborn errors of
metabolism? Anybody ever hear inborn
errors of metabolism? Okay. Inborn
errors of metabolism are things that are
missing during the formation of the
embryo in the early stages in the first
couple of weeks of the embryo's life and
the baby comes out with stuff that
doesn't happen properly. For instance,
how many of you heard of lactose
intolerance? You drink milk, eat cheese,
eat ice cream, you get bubbly
intestines, and it's painful and
bloating and diarrhea. It's called
lactose intolerance because you're
missing the enzyme lactase because mama
was missing something where that enzyme
was being formed. You can make up the
difference by supplementing with lactase
and you take the enzyme and then go
knock yourself out, you know, all the
ice cream and cheese you want and no
problem. Same thing is true with
fructose intolerance. Um, same thing
similar is true to PKU, phenino keto
ura, where where mama left out the piece
that's required to to properly break
down an amino acid called phenol
alanine. If you don't properly break
down phenyl alanine, the metabolic
pieces that are left over that aren't
broken down will cause retardation. Now,
what you have to do here for this is to
avoid it. And so, by law, any food
product or anything you're going to eat
or put in your mouth that has phenol
alanine, they have to say, "Warning PKU
patients, this product contains phenol
alanine. do not take it if you're a P
PKU patient. So by avoidance, you can
prevent the disease. Same thing is true
with type 1 diabetes is an inborn error
metabolism. It's not a genetic thing.
Mama is missing something when the cells
that form insulin, the beta cells, they
were never formed. And so the baby is
going to be on insulin for the rest of
its life. It's an inborn error
metabolism. We have type 1 diabetes.
Type two diabetes is a simple mineral
deficiency. It's easily reversed. Now in
black people, they have a disease called
cickle cell anemia. The same disease in
white people is calledthalosmia. This is
where the mother is having the baby go
down the assembly line. And when the
bone marrow is being formed, the part
that makes the hemoglobin, there's
something missing. And the hemoglobin
has what's called the cickle cell trait
or the thalismia trait. You're missing
nutrients. Instead of being like this
normal red blood cell over here looks
like a little donut, they will sickle
and look like grains of wheat, maybe
even look like a sickle. And so they you
can see where these would clog up little
arteries and cause strokes and swelling
and all kinds of other complications.
And so by supplementing with the 90
essential nutrients, which we'll get
into in a minute, and taking some extra
selenium and some extra B6, you can
prevent people who have that cickle cell
trait from sickling. Been doing this
since 1991 in people in Atlanta, Georgia
in the Georgia cickle cell foundation.
You all heard of Down syndrome. Down
syndrome is not genetically transmitted.
Down syndrome is actually caused by a
zinc deficiency in the first 10 minutes
of pregnancy. I've actually reversed
them uh not after the baby's born, not
after 91 days, but Lauren Conval, Evil
Conval's niece-in-law called me about 12
years ago and she said, "Look, doc, I've
got a pregnancy. It's two and a half
months along uh by two different tests
for two different laboratories. They
tell me I have a baby with Down
syndrome. I don't want to have an
abortion and they tell me you might be
able to help me." I said, "Well, we've
done it in animals. We've never done it
in humans." And she said, "Well, I'm not
going to get an abortion. So, you know,
this is not going to be a problem. Just
let's do it." And so what I did was give
her the 90 essentials of nutrients and
give her some extra zinc and the baby
was born perfectly normal later on. Done
it several times since. Okay. Early on
in pregnancy with a down syndrome baby.
Apparently they are reversible. But once
the baby's 91 days, you can't. You've
all heard of spinoipida. One of the
lawsuits I lodged against the FDA was
over folic acid supplementation and
prenatal vitamins. Until we sued them,
there was no law requiring folic acid
and prenatal vitamins and babies would
be born with spinoipida. This baby also
has a zinc deficiency because got club
feet. This baby has a gluten intolerance
because they barn with no hair. All this
is avoidable by perfect nutrition and
corrective diets before conception.
Whose fault is this? The OBGYn. I told
you I discovered the first non-human
case of cystic fibrosis and Reese's
monkeys primate center in Atlanta,
Georgia, Emory University. And uh of
course they fired me for saying it
wasn't genetic. And about 5 years ago,
we began to send Jerry Lewis papers and
and records of kids whose muscular had
been reversed. We had learned the cause,
prevention, and cure of musphy in
animals in 1957. And over the years, I
had used it. Every once in a while, I'd
see a musphy kid and we were able to
reverse it. I'd see another one three or
four years later, and we were able to
reverse it, but wasn't big enough
numbers to to make any impact on
science. About 5 years ago, one of our
associates, Marvin Rob, who was a Navy
Seal, but he started out as an Amish
kid. When he reached 18, he shaved his
beard off, gave his team of horses to
his brother, joined the Navy, and became
a Navy Seal. Very highly decorated. He
came back and he was just really
offended because the medical doctors are
using the Amish as an ATM machine
telling him all their disease were
genetic and there's nothing you could do
about it and they were just ripping
these poor people off. So we gave Jerry
Lewis all the paperwork and so Jerry
Lewis got excited said Jerry we don't
want any money. We've already spent the
time and money and effort. We we now
know what we believe is the cause and
cure of mus. Do you want to be the one
you're these are Jerry's kids you want
to be the one to make the announcements?
He got excited. He took all this data to
the medical committee of Musv Foundation
and they fired Jerry Lewis four years
ago. That's why he's not doing the
telephone. They fired Jerry Lewis. He's
not sick. He's not dead. He's doing
shows in Vegas every night. They fired
Jerry Lewis. Somebody needs to go to
jail. Well, 1989 with Maland, I went to
China and went to Kishan Province,
China. Why did I go there? Because
everybody knows the Kishan disease,
which occurs in 13 out of every thousand
kids there, is a cardiopathy heart
disease. So, sudden heart death is
caused by deficiency of selenium. We
know a deficiency of selenium is the
cause of cystic fibrosis and the cause
of muscular history. And I I reason that
if this is true and everybody including
the World Health Organization agreed
that kan disease is cardiammyopathy
heart disease caused by a selium
deficiency. There had to be some kids
there in China with cystic fibrosis and
musky. And experts when I asked him
about it they said no come on wall. Um
cystic fibrosis and muscularity only
occur in white kids from Eastern
European origin. Well I knew that wasn't
true because I had autopsied black kids
and oriental kids, Asian kids that had
these diseases cystic fibrosis and
muscy. So I knew they couldn't be true.
So we went there, passed all the tests,
did everything we needed to do to
satisfy the Chinese government that we
knew we were doing, they were going to
get their credit for it, and did 1,700
autopsies in kids under the age of 10.
595 of them, exactly 35% had cystic
fibrosis and 100% had muscular
destrophy. Published it in English,
published it in the journal of trace
element research, very wellrespected
scientific journal in the United States,
the equivalent journals in Chinese, in
China, sent copies to the muscular
foundation, to the cystic fibrosis
foundation. Never heard a word from
them. Somebody needs to go to jail. You
all have heard of cerebral paly.
Cerebopaly is one of these gradient
diseases. It's a gradient disease.
Different degrees of severity. Baby's
born with 10% of his cerebellum, which
is the part of the brain that's damaged
when you have cerebopal paly. 10%
damage, 10% underdevelopment, the baby's
going to kind of walk like Charlie
Chaplan. And with braces and some
physical therapy, they can kind of
circumvent that disability. They have a
25% underdevelopment of their
cerebellum. They kind of flop around a
little bit. with their arms and hands
and upper body as well as their legs and
you know they have cerebal palsy. They
have 50% development they're going to be
restricted to a wheelchair. This girl
here has 90% underdevelopment of her
cerebell the size of a grape instead of
a tangerine. And you can see she has
clamps on her head holding it up. Uh
since she was born and she's 11 years
old here since she was born people have
to wipe her bottom. Here she is um it's
now two years later after this picture
was taken. She's now 13. She's 11 in
this picture. She's going through
puberty. Somebody's gonna have to change
her tampons, wipe her bottom, feed her,
do everything, do everything for her,
give her massages three or four times a
day to prevent pressure ulcers, all this
machinery that's needed to move her
around. Care, extraordinary care. It's
$5 million a year for that child.
There's 10,000 babies born with this
disease in America every year. Whose
fault is that? OBGYn. Totally
preventable. This is the part of the
brain that's underdeveloped when you
have the cerebellum, when you have
cerebral palsy. Same way with belly
button hernas. It's a gradient disease.
Here's a pretty typical belly button
hernia the size of a walnut. Just you
give that baby hypnotic either by
injection or gas. Puts local anesthesia
around that. 10 minutes the procedure is
done. You've you've repaired that belly
button hernia. But the baby shouldn't
have to go through that. Mama was
missing something during pregnancy for
that to happen. This next one, the baby
was born dead. A vascular shock because
the defect went from the two inches
below the belly button through the belly
button to two inches above it. And
there's no skin over it. And the stomach
and the spleen and some of the
intestines are hanging out. And you can
see we're why didn't the the OB/GYN know
that that baby was suffering from
vascular shock? Well, he was in the
bathroom giving himself drugs. This one
here, the defect goes from the pubic
bone all the way to the middle of the
chest. And here the liver and the
stomach, the spleen, and all the
intestines are hanging out. You can see
how that baby would die from vascular
shock being born that way. Where where
was the OBGYn? That baby's perfect.
Brain is perfect, lungs are perfect,
heart's perfect, liver is perfect,
everything's perfect. It died from
vascular shock because all its insides
are hanging out during birth. That baby
was delivered by cescareian section
would be alive today. Somebody needs to
go to jail here. Same way with cleft
palent. It's a gradient disease.
Different degrees of severity. Whether
you're rich or poor, if the mother's
deficient in zinc in the first 3 to
seven weeks of pregnancy, you can get
cleft pallet and many other defects.
Kids are born deaf, congenital deafness.
Doctors want you to believe it's
genetic. And there's they're raising
money. They have all these funds to
raise money to prevent, you know, change
the genes, fix the genes. It's caused by
deficiency of a single mineral called
manganesees. Not magnesium, manganesees.
deficiency in the first 3 to 7 weeks of
pregnancy causes congenital deafness.
This new book that pharmacist Ben talked
about when he introduced me is called
epigenetics. Epigenetics tells you that
the genetic theory of disease
transmission is one of those dead
theories. There is not a single disease
that's transmitted genetically. The
death of the genetic theory of disease
transmission. The death of the genetic
theory of disease transmission. There's
thousands of dead theories. the medical
trade in the halls of science and the
epigenetics tells you that these
diseases that are said to be genetic are
preventable many of them reversible with
nutritional supplementation prior to
conception a lot of diseases that like
Huntington disease which is a disease
that kind of falls in between Parkinson
disease and MS ler's disease is said to
be genetic occurs in people 50 years of
age and older come on okay we'll get
into that in a little bit totally
preventable reversible the death of the
genetic theory of disease transmission
that's me in 1977 with one of my cystic
fibrosis monkeys You've all heard of
obesity. Whereas the medical theory and
the government's theory of why America
is obese and overweight is because we
don't exercise enough. We eat too much.
Well, following their theory to eat less
and exercise more, we became the number
one obese nation in the world. We're
number one. The only thing we can brag
about being number one in the health
area is we're obese by following their
theory. So obviously that theory didn't
work. So what causes obesity? What
causes people to over be overweight if
it's not lack of exercise and eating too
much? Well, it's a simple nutritional
deficiency. You take the nutrients and
it goes away. Okay, we'll get into that
in some detail if we have time. Multiple
scerosis, a disease that historically
occurred primarily in people between the
ages of 30 and and 60. MS today, in the
last 10 years, the peak of the
demographic curve of of who gets MS are
kids under the age of 12. They're even
diagnosing MS now in 10-month old
babies, 10-month old babies. How's that
happening? Free radical damage to the
mile in the brain. Free radical damage
to the mile of the brain. Well, why is
it now we're getting it in young babies
10 months old than it used to be in
people 50 years old? That's because
their babies are getting free radicals
damaging their mile of the brain. Well,
where are they getting the free
radicals? Apple juice. What happens when
you cut an apple in half and leave it
exposed to the air without putting lemon
juice on it? It turns brown. What's
turning brown in the apple? It's
oxidation of the oil in the apple. Apple
juice is not taken care of very well.
It's one of the first nonformmula things
you give a baby is, you know, an ounce
of apple juice and 8 ounces of water in
their little bottle. They're they're
giggling. They're happy. But the free
radicals that build up because of the
apple juice oxidizing, the oil in the
apple juice oxidizing causes MS in
little babies. Thrombotic stroke again
used to be in people over the ages of
50, 60, 70. Now the peak of the
demographic curve or kids under the age
of 18. How's that happening? Well,
thrombotic stroke doesn't occur because
of genetics. Thrombotic stroke doesn't
occur just out of dumb luck. It's caused
by an omega-3 essential fatty acid
deficiency or ratio problem between
omega-3s, sixes, and nines. That's
another one of my lawsuits against the
FDA. Because I prevailed in federal
court, I can legally say that you can
actually prevent thrombotic stroke. You
can prevent pulmonary embolism. You can
prevent coronary thrombosis and deep
veins thrombosis simply by supplementing
with omega-3 essential fatty acids and
having a perfect ratio between omega-3
sixes and nines. Before I sued them and
won in federal court, I couldn't say
that without getting put in jail. How
many of you give your kids and grandkids
under the age of five 1,000 milligrams
of supplemental omega-3s every day?
Gosh, I don't see any hands going up.
That's why your kids are going to die
before you from MS and stroke and stuff
like that. Heart attacks, Keshan
disease, cardiammyopathy, heart disease.
So, how come this is happening now? Why
are they getting all these strokes? We
didn't get strokes until we're in our
50s, 60s,7s. That's because we were
getting omega-3s when we were kids.
Well, wait a minute. We didn't
supplement. Well, yeah, you did. It was
in egg yolks. Our kids now are living on
Fruity Pebbles and apple juice, sunny
delight, and shredded wheat. Welch is
grape juice and Cheerios. How many
omega-3s are in them? Nothing. Nothing.
Zero. Zero. You better be supplementing
your kids and your grandkids before
they're conceived all through the
pregnancy developed and from the moment
they're born with all 90 essential
nutrients and you'll avoid all this
stuff. Now, the most politically charged
of all of the congenital events, birth
effects if you will, is another one of
these gradient disease like belly button
hernas, cerebral palsy. It's totally
100% preventable, but once the baby's
born, it's irreversible. Homosexuality
in both males and female occurred in the
first 3 to seven weeks of pregnancy.
There's a part of the brain called the
preoptic hypothalamus that controls not
your gender but controls who you go
after for sex. Your gender is determined
genetically. But there's a piece of your
brain that determines who you will go
after for sex, a boy or a girl. And it
could be different from your genetic
sex. And that's what happens with
homosexuality, asexuality,
hermaphrodites, all that kind of stuff.
Because what goes on up here is
different from your genetic sex. Now,
interex babies, ones that are they're
hermaphrodites. They have both male and
female parts. The medical system in
America, they will look for bar bodies,
which is the second female hormone, the
second, excuse me, chromosome, second
female chromosome called a bar body. And
you can see that every nucleus of the
white blood cell in a blood sample from
a newborn baby that has hermaphrodite
has both a male and female parts. When
they have the bar bodies, um, they're
female genetically. And here's some
real, this is a line drawing obviously,
but here here's bar bodies in some real
XX female blood smears. And you can see
in a male XY, there's nucleoli because
it's getting ready to divide, but
there's no bar bodies. Bar bodies are
totally different than the nuclei. And
so when they find a baby that is
hermaphrodite, but they have bar bodies,
they will surgically remove the penis
and the testicles, do a little plastic
surgery and beat their chest and say, "I
did good. I did good for this baby."
Well, 85% of the time when the baby's
born hermaphrodite up here, they're
preoptic hypothalamus, they're a male.
85% of the time they're a male. And our
pediatric surgeons and obgines have done
some of the most cruel things to these
babies born hermaphrodites. While in
Europe, in Scandinavia, they wait till
the babies are 10 years old because by
the time they're 10 years old, the
babies know which one they are. They're
preoptic hypothalamus. They have both
parts. And you ask the baby, they're 10
years old. Well, are you, you know, you
got both parts there, Frank. I mean,
it's obvious. You know that. But really,
which one are you? Are you a girl or a
boy? Well, I'm a boy. And so, they cut
off the vagina and the ovaries and do
some plastic surgery and then make him a
boy. Even though genetically it might be
a female. It's the kindest thing to do.
Do it that way. One more and then I'll
show you the part of the brain that's
afflicted. And then we'll get to the
bottom line here. This fell here, very
famous eye surgeon in central
California. His name is Richard. And
Richardathered several cute kids. very
famous for dealing with laser surgery to
tack down detached retinas. Uh he was
very active in his church. He was very
active in in things like the Rotary
Club, Rotary International and Lions
Club, raising money for projects. When
his last child reached 18 years of age,
he went from central California to
Denver, Colorado, had his penis and
testicles amputated, had a vagina made,
had breast implants, got hormone
treatments, and went from Richard to
Renee because since he was 10 years old,
he knew up here that he was a she. Now,
this is a part of the brain that's
afflicted. This is not a part of the
brain that's necessary for life. I mean,
you you cut this braid off here, you're
going to die. You cut this part of the
brain off, you're going to be a
vegetable and just lay there like a
worm. You cut this part of the brain
off, you're going to be dead. But this
little peninsula here, the the preoptic
hypothalamus, about the size of my
little finger, if there's no cells in
there, there's about 400 cells in there
normally. If there's no cells in there,
the individual is asexual. Everybody has
a crazy Aunt Ruthie or crazy uncle Frank
who the legend goes they went on a date
when they were 20 and their boyfriend or
girlfriend jilted them. I don't know how
you jilt somebody after one date, but
they said they jilted them and they
never went out again because they were
so wounded from being jolted after that
one date and they died never having get
gotten married. Well, they were asexual.
They just really weren't interested in
sex, but everybody else is going on
dates. So, they thought they'd try it
once and so on. If there's a few more
cells in there, say 25 to 50, they're
bisexual. They love having orgasms, but
they don't care if it's a male or
female. You got a few more cells in
there. It depends on what part of that
preoptic hypothalamus is involved. Let's
say you got 150 cells in there now, but
they're in one place, which drives you
to chase boys. But genetically, you're a
male. You're being pulled by your
preoptic hypothalamus to chase boys.
Okay? You're a male homosexual. If
you're a female and it tells you to
chase females, you're a lesbian. You
have 250 cells to 400 cells, you're
heterosexual. That's how it works.
Totally preventable. However, after the
baby's born, can't go back. You can't
put the genie back in the bottle. Here's
the bottom line, folks. All vertebrates,
whether you're a hummingbird or a human
being or an elephant, require 90
essential nutrients. How long do you
need oxygen? For life. How long do you
need water? For life. How long do you
need the 90 essential nutrients? For
life. There's 60 minerals, 16 vitamins,
12 essential amino acids, three
essential fatty acids. And they're
called essential for two reasons. Number
one, we can't make them. We must consume
them every day, either as food or
supplements. And if they're missing,
secondly, if they're missing for any
length of time, you get horrible
diseases, all of which are fatal. Plants
only need three minerals to make good
seeds for the next generation. We need
60. So, if you're eating a pretty good
slice of organically grown multigrain
bread baked with love by the pastor's
wife in the church on Sunday when he
gives his very best sermon he's ever
given his whole life, you're 57 mineral
short. This article is from Food
Chemistry. And Food Chemistry is a very
wellrespected scientific journal. It's
very boring. just tells you where they
grow food and how many nutrients is in
that food from that county or that plat
of land, how many pollutants or what the
pollutant load is. This particular
issue, April 16th, 2012, they did an
article where they analyzed the
nutritional value and the pollutant load
in baby formulas, eight classic baby
formulas in America and Canada that
everybody knows and respects. Gerbers,
Infamil, Similac, ones like that. And
they said commercially available baby
foods may contain less than 20% of the
recommended levels of minerals and
vitamins. Dog food has 100%. Laboratory
rat food has 100%. Chicken food has
100%. And your babies, grandb babies and
babies have less than 20%. Somebody
needs to go to jail. That's why you must
supplement. You cannot depend on quote
eating well. You cannot depend on eating
well. 60 years ago, we had perfected
perfect dog food. We spent a hundred
billion dollars perfecting dog food.
What did we get for that? Well, we
tripled our lifespan over 60 years. 60
years ago, an old dog was 8 years old.
10 dog is 25. We eliminated 900
different diseases that still plague
humans, including all birth defects you
can name and 10 times that many you
can't. We didn't do that with organ
transplants. We didn't do that with
genetically engineered protein, stem
cells, or wonder drugs. We did it simply
by putting vitamins and minerals in
their dog food. This is um the weekend
magazine from the Glob and Mail up in
Canada. The Glob and Mail is their
equivalent of the USA Today. This
article was written by a medical doctor
and he was wanting you to eat real food
and not take vitamin mineral tablets and
pills and capsules. I do both. For
breakfast, I'll have four poached eggs
and a steak. I'll have a baked sweet
potato with butter and cinnamon. I'll
have all my supplements. For lunch, I
have a couple of snacks. I have another
light load of my supplements. At dinner
time, I'll have some grilled salmon with
a great salad. I'll have some dessert.
And I will have my supplements. I eat
very well. I have steak at least once a
day. At least once a day. Better yet,
three times a day, right? I avoid oil. I
avoid burning my foods. I won't eat if
it's burnt. I avoid gluten. No wheat,
brother, and oats. I take all my
supplements. You see, if you eat well,
how many milligrams of calcium are you
going to get from that apple? You can't
tell. How many micrograms of selenium
are you going to get from oneinch wedge
of that apple? You can't tell. How many
international units of vitamin A or beta
carotene are you going to get from
eating a slice of that tomato? You can't
tell. So, I'm going to eat well, but I'm
going to also take my supplements
because I know how many milligrams, how
many units, how many micrograms of
everything I'm getting because I'm not
going to leave my life from the life of
my kids and grandkids and great
grandkids and great great grandkids up
to chance to the throw of the dice, what
may or may not be in that food. I'm
going to make sure everything is in
there perfect. The equivalent of not
supplementing would be to put a couple
of shovels full of dirt from Texas in
the crank case of your car. Say, "Well,
there's probably oil in there cuz that
dirt's from Texas." That'd be really
stupid, wouldn't it? When you just eat
well and you don't supplement with
everything you know properly to to make
sure you get everything you need. Worse
yet if you don't supplement your kids
and grandkids and great grandkids. Rich
people thousands of years ago.
Royalties, wealthy noblemen, wealthy
merchants would get their minerals from
mummy dust. You go to the grave robber
who had already sold off all the jewelry
and the clothes and trinkets that were
buried with them. But he kept the mummy
because there was more money in the
mummy than was in the trinkets. You go
to the everybody knew where the grave
robbers were. Just like back in the
probation days, everybody could get
whiskey even though it was il illegal,
right? And so go to the grave robbery
and say, "Look, I got arthritis in my
right hip." And he go cut the right hip
off the mummy, grind it up, give you the
powder. In six weeks time, your hip was
cured. It would go away. The arthritis
would go away. Why? Because human joints
have condritin sulfate, glucosamine
sulfate, hyaluronic acid, collagen,
vitamin A, vitamin D, calcium,
magnesium. It has all this stuff and it
would repair that joint. Now, human
joints are a lot more expensive than
chicken joints, right? And so, slaves
and subsistence farmers couldn't get
their minerals in the same fashion. So,
where did they get their minerals? From
wood ashes. Wood ashes not really ashes
are the plant minerals that are left
when you burn away the wood. Powder
that's left in the fireplace, the wood
stove is really plant minerals. You
throw it in the garden and the corn and
the peas and the sweet potatoes and the
onions and the tomatoes and and peppers,
whatever you're growing out there suck
up these minerals. You throw them in the
garden. The plants suck them up. You eat
the plants. You get your minerals in
that fashion. Well, that was the way we
supplemented with our minerals. That's
way the the traditional way we got
minerals for thousands and thousands and
thousands and thousands and thousands of
years until 3:00 in the afternoon,
Monday, September 4th, 1882 on Pearl
Street in New York City on the bluff
overlooking the construction of the
Brooklyn Bridge where this fellow here,
Thomas Edison, pulled the switch on the
first commercial electric generating
plant. Within 10 years, every town in
every municipality in every city in the
industrialized world converted from wood
is a universal fuel to electricity. How
many wood ashes? How many plant minerals
are left over when you fuel your home
with electricity instead of wood? Zero.
And what did you replace your
traditional source of nutritional
minerals with? Nothing. And here comes a
wellrespected individual doctor saying,
"Now, don't you supplement with
vitamins, minerals, you can overdose.
You know, you better be saving your
money for pharmaceuticals. You're going
to need it as you get older." This is a
satellite picture from a 100 miles up.
Southern California agricultural land.
This is Mexico down here. Yum, Arizona
over here. Pacific Ocean over here. This
is the salt and sea. So, you know
exactly where this is at in Southern
California. The salt and sea is a salt
lake about onetenth the size of the
great salt lake in Utah. But what don't
you see here is that nutritional
minerals do not occur in a uniform
blanket around the crust of the earth.
Nutritional minerals occur in veins like
chocolate and chocolate of ice cream.
These different colors and swirls and
whirls are telling you these whirls and
swirls are made up of different
minerals, different mixtures of
minerals, different amounts of each one.
And the only way we can guarantee that
every mouthful and every animal that
eats soybeans, they're grown here, corn
that's grown here, whatever might be
grown here, we're going to put in their
feed, we're going to give them, we're
going to supplement them with everything
we know they need for maximum life, no
birth defects, going to maximum
production of milk, meat, eggs. When you
look at that label on the dog food, on
the chicken food, on the dairy food, on
beef cattle feed, that label reflects
only what we put in there, not what the
food got out of the soil. What the food
got out of the soil is value added, but
it's a throw of the dice. So we put
everything we know they need for perfect
everything. We put it in there. This is
a compost pile that contains 77 minerals
in it. These are plant derived minerals.
This is a compost pile. This is plants.
There's 100 cubic miles of this stuff.
There is a 10,000ear supply if everybody
in the earth uses this stuff. These guys
are standing on a road 3,000 foot
elevation above sea level. This white
cap is 25 foot thick marine limestone.
We know it's marine limestone because of
animal and plant fossils in the
limestone from the ocean. This has zero
pollution. It was under the sea for
thousands and thousands and thousands of
years. The ultimate question is, do you
put oil in your car before the engine
burns up or after the engine burns up?
You put oil in your car before the
engine burns up. You change the oil
every 3,000 miles, whatever the
maintenance book says, you'll get
300,000 mi out of that engine. If you
put water in that car instead of oil,
that car might not go 50 miles. So, you
know, to put the oil in the car. Well,
Methusela lived to be 969. Those in the
Old Testament who begat so- and so who
begat so- and so who begat so- and so,
they live to be 150, 200, 300. So, who
knows how long we can live if we do
everything right. So, isn't it insane to
supplement with everything we know we
need in perfect amounts? Eat right, but
make sure we're getting everything
perfectly like we do putting oil in cars
before the engine burns up. Now, myself,
next month, using the Chinese method of
aging, I'll be 75. Using the American
aging system, I'll be 74. I have not
been to a doctor with me being the
patient for the last 68 years. I've
never been a prescription medication. I
have no health problems whatsoever, and
nobody's going to steal an airplane with
me on it. Now, if everybody were like me
medically, the medical system would be
real humble if their patients only came
to them once every 75 years, wouldn't
they? They'd be real humble. I've been
taking the 90s essential nutrients twice
a day since I was 9 years old. Been
taking this program twice a day since I
was nine. Now, I'm not stupid enough to
think that I, a nine-year-old kid,
figured this out by myself. I figure I
had some divine guidance there, right?
And so, I feel that I'm obligated to
keep sharing this with people. if I had
divine guidance, got rid of one of my
health problems when I was nine, that
was it. Never had a health problem
again. It's all preventable. There's
only two reasons why you won't get the
result you're looking for. Only two
reasons, maybe three. Number one, you're
underdosing. A 200lb person taking
enough for a 50 lb kid ain't going to
work as they say in France. And then you
can't absorb it. You're dosing
perfectly, but you're only getting 10%
because you can't absorb it. You are not
what you eat, you are what you absorb.
Thirdly, you're underdosing and you
can't absorb. So 10% of nothing's not
very much. The most common reason why
people are not absorbing is gluten
intolerance. People say, "I'm
gluten-free. I mean, I am obsessive
about it. I am gluten-free." You have a
dog. Yep. You have dry dog food. Yep.
You're not gluten-free because dried dog
food is made from gluten. You have a
cat. Yep. Give them dried cat food. Yep.
Well, you're not gluten-free. Well, I
can't get my spouse to give up gluten.
Well, you're not gluten-ree then.
Everybody in the household, including
the mother-in-law, the spouse, the dog,
the cat, the bird, the fish, because of
crosscontamination, the laundry, the
couch where everybody watches TV, the
food preparation surface, the bed you
sleep in, everything, everybody in the
household's got to be gluten-free.
Otherwise, you're not gluten-free. And
then, of course, you need stomach acid.
You cannot be drinking alkaline water
during meals because you neutralize your
stomach acid to absorb minerals, to
digest proteins, to absorb B12. Your
stomach pH got to be pH 1.2. It's got to
be like battery acid. It also keeps your
stomach sterile so you don't have yeast
and bacteria growing there. You won't
have reflux. Make your reflux go away.
So when people tell me they haven't
gotten the results, you have to go back
and do a little investigation, do a
little housekeeping, figure out why
you're not absorbing. Are you
underdosing? Well, you have to look at
all those things because this program
I've been doing for 36 years will never
fail. If it fails, it means you're not
absorbing or you're underdosing or both.
And thank you very much for being a good
audience.
[Music]